what's up everybody I'm Walter Brennan
yak and this is top five
I love Dragon Ball Z and gotta be
kidding me Stanley episode is over guys
you can't be on the show every week oh
hey Walter I was on my way to a party
and I want to pick up my bill costume
people just can't get enough bill oh
sure yeah so what are you filming for a
top five this week top five best DVD
transformation what what you're doing a
top five of DBZ and you didn't invite me
well I'll usually do these by myself
[Music]
these are the top five Dragon Ball Z
transformation
did you get that out of your system yeah
sorry about that one of the coolest
things about Dragon Ball Z is the
transformations that the characters go
through just when you think a certain
hero or villain has reached their
maximum potential they go even further
beyond their previous limits and reach a
level that surpasses what we thought
possible on the show these
transformations can last from a few
seconds to multiple episodes while we're
well aware of the new heights these
characters have reached in Dragon Ball
super and even back in GT we're keeping
this list strictly to DBZ in the main
show no movies are specials
let's kick this list off with number 5
number 5 evil booze transformation into
super boot while the Buu saga was
definitely a mixed bag that ended the
show it still had some great ideas and
characters thrown in some of the
different forms of Buu were pretty
clever majin buu was starting to take a
turn to the light when his friend mr.
Satan is shot after going into a rage
and healing him Buu expelled his dark
side in the form of evil Buu pretty much
the opposite of his more rotund
counterpart evil Buu was skinny gray and
all bad after a battle that has evil Buu
turns fat boo into chocolate evil Buu
consumes his forebearer and begins a
terrifying transformation
[Music]
super brew was definitely the most
intimidating of any of the incarnations
of majin buu up to this point while he
would change several times more
including into his original form Kid Buu
this was the transformation that got rid
of a playful almost innocent fat foo and
replaced him with a menacing
unpredictable killer now I know the
music in this show can be a hotly
debated topic but I grew up with the
Bruce Faulconer score and loved it super
Bruce theme is one of my favorite tracks
from the entire show
[Music]
hmm I really want some chocolate now
number four cells transformation into
perfect cell cells transformations are
tied heavily into the saga of the show
his constant pursuit for perfection paid
off in a big way
while his absorption of Android 17 was
quite startling to behold it was his
forceful assimilation of Android 18 that
created one of the best transformations
in the series after taunting Vegeta that
his perfect form would give him a proper
challenge cell has given the go-ahead to
absorb Android 18 while the other Z
fighters try to stop this from occurring
they were not able to halt xviii demise
and the creation of perfect cell
[Music]
what sets this one apart a bit is trunks
is desperation to try and stop it from
happening even after it began Future
Trunks came from a world that the
androids destroyed and is frantic to do
whatever it takes to prevent similar
destruction in this timeline
despite his determination it was too
late
[Applause]
it was a landmark villain for the series
and a favorite of a lot of fans from
gruesomely sucking the life out of
innocent people to reaching its perfect
form cell is one of the most formidable
antagonists the show ever had this is
only number four what can be greater
than perfection number three Goku's
first Super Saiyan transformation this
is pretty much the granddaddy of all
Goku going super saiyan for the first
time was a big moment for DBZ and set a
precedent that is still going today even
if you're a casual fan of this show you
know the story but it's a great one Goku
and Frieza had been going head-to-head
for a while at this point with many
already dead on Planet Namek in the wake
of freezes occupancy there he decides to
take one more life to really stick it to
our hero Goku's best friend
Krillin is killed right in front of him
in a cool act of evil this is the thing
that sends Goku over the edge his rage
is channeled into powering up to a level
that hadn't been seen in thousands of
years
[Music]
this being the first time we ever saw a
Super Saiyan was unbelievably exciting
going blonde hair never looked so cool I
know it inspired me I was a fan before
this but this was the moment that hooked
me forever afterwards I constantly drew
Dragon Ball Z characters I sent one of
Super Saiyan Goku into Toonami as they
would show fanart during breaks from the
show my picture never made it on there
but it was great to see how many kids
were just as inspired by DBZ as I was
never made it on huh now properly sucked
anyway number two
Goku's transformation into Super Saiyan
3 a bit like Goku his first
transformation into Super Saiyan Goku's
transformation into Super Saiyan 3 was
another game changer Goku is confronting
majin buu and honestly showing off a bit
he basically gave Buu and bhavati a
crash course in Super Saiyan history
before powering up into this new form
this is a Super Saiyan and this you
could just called this a Super Saiyan 2
and this
and to go he's been processed freon he
had been training for years in the other
world and learned more than a few new
tricks this one was a doozy
let's not forget Goku nearly destroyed
the planet by powering up here I mean at
least a few people probably died
[Music]
we care with the street
and once again that Bruce style corner
score is super catchy even if you don't
like it it's got to get you pumped a
little bit right
[Music]
[Applause]
there are a lot of badass
transformations in DBZ so before we get
to number one here are a few honorable
mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Dragon Ball Z
transformation is Gohan's first Super
Saiyan 2 transformation
LM go on ok I'll go on behind piccolo he
is my favorite character and this was
him at his peak the emotion behind this
moment is still captivating to watch go
on has been pushed to the edge his
friends are getting demolished by cell
juniors cell is mocking him trying to
bring out more power and to top it all
off the gentle Android 16 gives them
some touching final motivation that is
crushed by self it is not a sin to fight
for the right cause you are gentle you
do not like to hurt but it is because
you cherish life that you must protect
it it's a moment that felt like it was
in the making since the beginning of the
series go on had shown immense potential
and flashes here and there up until this
instant it was the culmination of years
of development and it did not let us
down
[Applause]
[Music]
Gohan was always a kind soul it's not
really in his nature to be this
aggressive fighter however it is that
inner conflict that always made him so
interesting he's a bit of a reluctant
hero and seeing his inner struggle was
consistently fascinating to watch I had
high hopes for him heading into the Buu
Saga but those expectations weren't
exactly met it's fight against cell and
going Super Saiyan 2 ended up being the
pinnacle for the first son of Goku in
DBZ but it left a big impression on me
and fans all over the world seeing our
favorite characters reach new heights
has always been a trademark fun aspect
to the show as they continue to ascend
and super maybe another list will be in
order down the road we want to know what
you guys think what is your favorite
Dragon Ball V transformation leave a
comment below and you can find me on
twitter at malcolm larae as well as on
my facebook fan page
malcolm ray for more content subscribe
to my personal channel youtube.com slash
awesome walter like when your facebook
page facebook.com slash awesome walter b
and follow me on twitter to take part in
more polls about what may be covered on
the show when I get the chocolate now oh
yeah my hunger level is over 9000
[Music]
you